the Joe Rogan experience they get mad
the at the top man there's no one who's
like you doesn't work hard right that's
the myth right that's the thing too it
was like man again the wrong word for it
right
passion hard whatever it is I mean you
don't hit it to craft maintaining it is
there's an art to that right because you
work so freaking hard to get to where
you're at and then you get there and
it's like aw [ __ ] what do I do it like
there's no rest there's no rest and
everything that was acceptable before
becomes unacceptable because now you're
up here you know I mean so it's like
yeah you have to you have to you have to
pick your shots and like you know I'm
saying can't really like just go crazy
like you did back in the day
so there's art to it you know what I
mean and that's how you really maintain
and stay in that spot and even level up
so do you consciously think okay balance
out enjoyment with things that I have to
do to stay disciplined 100% yeah 100%
that's a very smart way of looking at
yeah yep 100% like those there has to be
a balance of each because it's like
alright now I'm at this new level like
whether I want to behave like this or
not I put myself here I worked hard now
I'm with these elite [ __ ] so
this is the this is how I have to act
because I'm not down here anymore
I worked from here to get here yeah so
what happens you balance you put things
into place you do a little bit of this
and a little bit of that instead of a
lot of that you know I mean and you just
pick your shots and it's like you're
gonna get everything in the end this is
how it's just planned and how it's
supposed to be but you just piece it
together just a little bit differently
like I just turned 31 well damn I'm
about to be 32 that's young too a lot of
people that's old to some people as well
but for me it's like there's a whole new
mind state you know what I mean and I
feel like through my 20s I was actually
like a [ __ ] teenager and like now I'm
an adult so now I look at things a
little bit differently as like you know
I was
really a kid this is how you behave as
an adult for the rest of your life and
it still involves a whole bunch of
partying and having fun but the business
gets handled and things get approached
totally differently that's a balanced
way of looking at it man I love it
mm-hmm enjoy it this other think to like
people have to understand to to be
someone like you to be a very successful
rapper mm-hmm and to not expect you to
live the way you talk about all the time
right so ridiculous right all right like
you don't think he wants a party he's
talking about parties all the time I
think he wants to party party this is
just an act yeah yeah it's weird right
it's crazy as [ __ ] because people they
want you to be you they want me to be
myself right they want a party they
don't want to take shots they want to
smoke weed they want to stay up all
night yeah why is that bad it's nice so
many people want to do it but it gives
this image in some people's minds and
like frivolous life mmm frivolous
thinking partying mm-hmm
what are you doing drinking and smoking
and then they come around and do the
same thing because they want it it's
like I have like a weird place in life
where I think I'm like the key to a lot
of [ __ ] because it's like if you want to
enjoy yourself I'm a guy meter on I mean
it's like oh man I'm just [ __ ] gonna
live through it when we're shows up he's
gonna light the joint it's gonna be
amazing
if you want to [ __ ] be professional
like especially when what I do because
there's a whole lot of rappers who like
aren't business you know I mean they're
not thinking like that mm-hmm so for
those guys I'm their guy like they look
at me like where's how's his [ __ ]
together like he really handles his
business he talks to people he shows up
he does this he does that so to be the
party guy and the business guy it's like
amazing you know what I mean it's a it's
a lane that I kind of carved for myself
but it's me in real life so it's like
that's the only thing I have to do is
really just completely be myself just be
100 [ __ ] show up do my business thing
tell people to do the right thing and
[ __ ] light to joy that's it that's a
crazy business sir I'm good I'm straight
like that that's amazing
Mia people listen to this apart Wow
mmm-hmm you could beat yourself for a
living for a show bro is blessing
[Applause]